thank you for the lovely introduction
thank you to the sponsors as well so
yeah yeah so my name is Nikki I'm a
technical manager at a company called
futureland we're transforming access to
education online and before I was the
technical manager I've been a web
developer for a long long time
more than a decade as Saren said I don't
tell you how many how much morning but
I'm definitely on the developer end of
this sort of design and developers skill
set I've got an appreciation for
designer didn't work very long in this
industry and without having that but I'm
not a designer so I have to work really
closely with designers to ship the
products that we build I can't do it on
my own so I developed this really keen
interest in understanding and helping
developers and designers work together
more closely and effectively so this
talk is about one way of doing that so
today I want to talk to you about
developers and designers who want to
push their imaginations to the limit and
push the web to its limits and I'm gonna
talk about how one of our most used
solutions this grid fault sort of layout
they always fall back to you has served
us really well for a really long time
but the world has also moved on and so
can we
so this is what we're gonna cover Web
Design is getting boring
wistful a bit like putting myself out
there when I see that it's a bold
statement and I always like to say as
well hashtag not all websites website
it's really good really usable they love
the little timeline of the events that
happening today so I'm just gonna look
at a bit the history in a bit in the
context to look back to look forward and
then some final things have practical
tips of course sorry the reason you're
all here skipped over the middle bit and
there's some finally some sort of things
that I stumbled upon when I was doing
some of this work and cleaned it out for
me so let's start by going back why even
Briggs what is the point of them we've
all been using grapes and building them
for some time online and offline so why
are they going to
- first or page layout to answer that
question we need to go way back this is
the Pyramid Texts it's dated to around
2300 BC and it's the first example of
human writing they're like human
communication I could find online it's
still kind of blows my mind that humans
existed 3,000 years ago I mean which one
communicate with each other when we
wrote this stuff down and I can find it
on the internet and show it to you
because really this is so cool but I
would like you to know I think this is a
one column layout a few thousand years
later five six eight ad this is the
Birmingham Birmingham Kirin manuscript
again like beautiful stunning I can't
believe we have access to this kind of
stuff still one column this is page one
this is page two finally 808 ad we
finally get 3,000 years after chipping
away on those stone walls we get to the
two column layout well don't you miss
and I think the benefit that you can see
immediately here is that there's a lot
more information on this page it's a lot
more dense this is a medieval manuscript
text and you can see the benefit already
this is the sort of marginalia that came
a lot later than the original text of
the book and somebody's been able to
sort start relating sort of arranging
related concepts next to each other but
they can be separate but they can still
be connected to the main in text that
they refer to in the owners 20th century
the art minhwan exploded the great
system itself was named this is a book
called grid systems in graphic design
and that riemann sort of exploded and
flourished and this starts to look a lot
more similar to the kind of modular
component systems that we use today
massimo vignelli designed this uni grid
in 1972 something for exactly that
purpose so that the app the product that
this grid was used
were more consistent but easier to
create and easier to reproduce in
quicker and this still helps the
national park cartographers today they
use the unit grid to design the maps for
the park keep their layouts readable
make sure that one element is not very
bouncing another and this has a
practical benefit as well looking at
this it just looks really good that's
useful because it helps it make sure
that people when they're looking at the
maps around the park they're more likely
to stay looking at the maps for a longer
time and hopefully absorb more of the
information they need to stay safe and
have a good time it helps get their
message across but there are some bad
examples of using grids too like this
mystery it's from more than two years
ago now I don't think a huge amount has
changed
I'm really sorry to kind of keep
bringing up this example because it's a
little bit snarky I know and but I think
it just does show that you know you can
take without relying on this printer too
far this can be a problem and I'm not
knocking it the reason we do this is
because on many levels it works it's
modular it's easy to reproduce if you
use the Uni grid it makes the maps
really look really good and you know
make sure that you should take that
information and stay safe in the park
but it's also really boring you look at
this and you can see the clues in the
name it's called the CSS box model you
can have the margin on the inside or the
outside but it makes access you know
they're all the same shape communication
and design is this human impulse have
been trying to do it for 3,000 years it
has this kind of long and rich history
and I think it's a shame that we don't
make normal use of it
and then things like this
[Music]
it's really good that you can go on
Squarespace and get yourself a website
now anyone can do that fantastic but
again we're starting to lose the
benefits of this kind of 3,000 year old
history of the communication and design
when everything starts leaking so say me
and so off the shelf you run the risk of
not getting your message across
effectively as you could so the only
reason I'm really even giving this talk
is that three like many conversations
over many years with friends designer
friends and developer friends of mine at
work and they say hey we've got this box
we've made this layout you know what can
you do to make it look a bit more
interesting and for the last 10 years
all I've been able to really say is well
I could put rounded corners on it it's
not very satisfying and nobody's really
pleased with the answer and the only
reason we even have the ability to put
images and use CSS in browsers is
because designers got frustrated and
they wanted to add color they wanted to
use layout and use the fonts I'm not be
restricted and doesn't have to be just
rounded corners let's think a bit bigger
so I'm not the only one who thinks this
this is Jenna Simmons she's amazing
she's like one of my heroes she said
this during her video discussion at
Finister Pot last year she's one of the
people who's doing really amazing work
in kind of improving graphic design on
the web and improving typographical
design on the web she just she's a
designer and developer advocate at
Mozilla a member of the CSS working
group and she's really pushing this idea
not just by doing talks of Mysore
telling people about it but actually
working with the people who are kind of
implementing this stuff to make them a
better man she said this we're copying
each other's work too much too many
things that like medium to many things
of like web design out of 2007 ah 10
years ago too many things look like
copies of each other everybody's bored
so there is a way to make design better
on the web that way so once I started
thinking about this it was in my mind I
just started seeing everywhere these are
examples of graphic designers
or pushing the boundaries of their
layouts and you can do really
interesting things like this kind of the
line of text following the dress well
this really striking art direction that
kind of read draws you in and makes you
want to read the article I know we don't
need enough of that like look babe
headlines and stuff you know I think
this is much nicer these are all from
the same issue of one magazine somebody
there really liked this style but the
point of all these examples is that like
print can do this and for decades we've
been saying you know the web is not
print and that's true it isn't we
shouldn't try and make things all
exactly the same but if we have the
technological ability now to do it in a
sort of inclusive accessible practical
scalable way then I think that we should
be taking advantage of that so if we did
want to do something a bit more
interesting like this and we didn't have
CSS shapes how could we do have we done
it in the past well I'm sure you're
familiar with this you could go super
old-school justify mall the next in an
image I'm sure you know all the reasons
why this is a terrible idea I think that
a lot of web comics are still published
like this which I think it's a real
opportunity for somebody out there a
really interesting industry that would
really benefit it would be really great
if someone came along and sort of gave
publishers more options for doing this
kind of stuff but make them available to
a much wider audience if you didn't want
to put all your text in just one image
you could have every line of text
composition you know manually with spans
and paragraphs with JavaScript it's
still not particularly maintainable or
scalable or accessible maybe performant
there's probably lots of other ways that
you can think of as well Alderon great
so that's kind of where we're at before
CSS shapes like the kind of current
state of the art I think you can tell
where I'm going with this let's get away
from these boring rectangles we're stuck
in our own ways and stuff on these grids
but actually there's something that can
make things a lot more interesting for
us and a lot better Griggs are great for
all those reasons that legibility white
balance space you don't have to lose any
of that once you understand those rules
then you've put the time in to learn how
and why they work and you have
foundations and you know wines like this
then you can break the rules so you can
break out of the grid and there is a way
to do that
so we're on to the practical tips
section the first thing I'd let's talk
to you about shape outside shape outside
applied to an element makes the text
flow around fast element in the shape
that you've chosen hopefully quite
obviously named we're going to get into
some examples in a minute the caveat on
this at the moment the shape the element
your of shape floating around the missus
Sheila the other manatee must have must
be floated so mmm apparently I just
found out today that might change they
may be like fixing that up in this back
don't know about random rumors and
gossip and the element must also have
shape hi tumbling same layout so we're
just going to be covering the top three
values today I couldn't I had to sort
play around with it and I couldn't do
anything with intercept though you can't
already do with flips so I didn't ask
you clearly interesting if you want to
have a go down the play then you should
an ellipse I think it's like a type of
circle I told you I wasn't a design I
know I got some race I passed with mine
when I was doing this work would have
run T of my designer sort of colleague
but sticking to it um so let's have a
look at shape outside circle hopefully
is some surprising to you but it aligns
text around a circle these properties
are all very long sale they do what they
say on the tin so this is what it looks
like this is a very simple example if
you want to have this kind of red dot
layout you can do it however you like
and then you just have this kind of
one-liner to get her things are lining
around the shape it's really nice really
simple really easy and if shape outside
is not supported you just get your
standard sort of rectangle box key text
but you always have before you haven't
impacted your accessibility or your
readability
the circles easy way polygons so
simplest example of a polygon is a
triangle this is what it looks like
again and this was like really simple
examples you can set
like this and you just have this one
liner again to add the shape to the
property to kind of get this nice
alignment you can see that this is like
a little bit more complicated you
actually have to plot your points now we
can't just say oh it's a circle or it's
a square I guess if it was insert or
whatever getting a little bit more
complicated again if it's not supported
doesn't matter it just falls back great
and easy another example of a polygon
this is got the corner cut off and again
you can see when I'm starting to make
this shape about to sort of plot an
extra point to kind of figure out where
I want the text to kind of go so it's
starting to look a little bit more
complicated now like oh I've got to keep
all these numbers in my head if I want a
more complicated shape than a square
with a corner curve like what do I do
mmm I guess worse so I don't have a
space to put all of the points on but it
like basically goes like three polygons
can have infinite points I think so it
starts to look a bit more scary and it
starts to look like a bit of a pain in
the arse and a bit of a barrier to entry
like about to do all this work I might
have been bothered I can't how can I
convince my designer colleagues to help
me with this so we're very lucky that a
whole bunch of people have done a whole
bunch of good work to make this a lot
easier and there are some tools to help
us make these shapes so I have a video I
don't have any songs that's hopefully
this is okay this is Firefox nightly but
this tool has just landed in Firefox I
thinks everybody has access to this now
so I've got my dev tools everything and
I'm gonna go and select the element that
has the favorite player which is the cat
and then when I do that I'm sorry it's
so small you start getting these kind of
rules out here and there's a tiny little
button next to the shape outside and if
I click on it I can see the points that
I've got just blew my mind when I first
say look mom I'm a designer
so the lovely thing about this is that
everything updates in real time here so
once you've kind of sat and cleaned up a
bit and made it how you want you can
just copy those over and straight into
your code these tools also I'm not just
for shape upside I think there's like a
grid editor in there as well if you want
to do you CSS grid and I think yeah this
is just a black box so yeah go and have
a play with that because it's amazing
the power of the browser now is just
phenomenal if you don't like Firefox
there's an editor for Chrome as well it
works in a very similar way I don't know
if this one has grid I think it might be
just shapes but yeah it doesn't kind of
the same sort of thing and you can kind
of pick your points up and move them
around so that's it for CSS shape
polygon shape outside polygons I found
when I was doing this and stopped
playing and making up some examples even
with these tools and they're still
funding that's like a little bit of
extra work that sometimes I don't know
if I can really be bothered to do so
there's one last value I wanted to tell
you about where shape outside which
again I completely blew my mind when I
found out that it was just the cleverest
thing I've ever seen and that is the URL
value so this is a kind of similar
layout to the one we had before with the
cat same effect us before but way less
code this time we're not going to set
all of our points out directly or play
in a browser with it or anything like
that but we're still gonna do this but
we're still going to get the same effect
ah the magic is root you use a
transparent image and it picks up on the
Alpha Channel so you need a transparent
PNG or a transparent SVG it also works
with both of those and you just pop your
URL to image in there and there's this
new property the shape image threshold
so not point five there means all the
pixels that are more than 50%
transparent are the ones that it will
kind of pick up on and throw around so
I've got this p.m. this is a way more
common use case I think in my experience
anyway that you'll be aligning text
around an image rather than out just
shape so you may as well have the
browser do all the work for you I'm very
lazy
especially because you've already had to
do the work to like prepare the image
right if somebody's chance found out the
bits they don't want or value so you've
already done that work you may as well
use it rather than duplicate it all in
your points so that's all about the
shape outside let's have a look at
browser support how real is this like
when can I actually use it so okay it's
not too bad just coming in Firefox which
is great and very excited about that
edge under consideration good okay
never gonna be an IE okay well like over
time that's not going to become less of
a problem so yeah it's not supported in
all the browsers so we do have to be a
little bit careful about how we're using
it and sort of think about our
progressive enhancement and sort of
consider our four bucks I say only you
know consider the full bucks the great
thing about this is that this is fine
you know
it's a one-liner it doesn't impact a
performance to add it it looks really
good if you don't have it it still looks
really good
this is the sort of thing to watch out
for just kind of thinking through all
the cases and what might happen if
things aren't supported so that's it for
CSS shapes we have some friends who also
want to come and play CSS clipping so
you might be familiar with some of this
it works I think we kind of same way
that it doesn't like Photoshop or sketch
or one of those editors using a path to
draw shape and then the things inside
the path visible and the things outside
aren't let's look at some examples
before we go on to those the syntax is
exactly the same as CSS ships I love
that they've done this fitting is really
clever loads that are a barrier to entry
again and these names these shapes are
called the basic shapes in the sort of
geometry spec of browsers slightly
confusing CSS shapes basic shapes but
you know once you've got your head
around it it's great we can just use
them for everything very helpful so this
is the kind of thing that you can do
and again like I did this in the browser
tools of just playing and dragging
things around worth noting before we
dive in we think as well the clip path
works on SVG's as well as HTML elements
so I'm just using it one in an image
here or any other element and you could
do but they do work on SVG as well so
I'm sure you can imagine the kind of
things that you could do with this all
kinds of you know different shapes this
is really simple again and you don't
have to prepare your images you just do
it all in the browser a lot of times
when I've been doing this kind of thing
with designers it's been like quite a
round-trip and a lot of back-and-forth
like they were making image I mean I
upload it and then we look at it and
it's not quite right and then I say okay
boy give me another image and then I
upload it and then when you look at
student right so I've got with this you
just like sit and playing with the
points in the browser and it's just so
much quicker giving designers a lot more
control over the sort of end result I
think a lot quicker as well so this is a
real world example of clip art this is
the website that I work for futureland
this is what the amazing lemon grape TV
used to build a new module for the
homepage which is that top kind of
banner aspect and they wanted the steps
we call them the future steps to kind of
wiggle down between those images
sometimes also reflective of our
branding although not apparently on this
slide this is how all of this stuff like
CSS clip path MCCS s shapes uses any CSS
unit so it can be responsive I think
they use calc and percentages to make
this work Remz ends whatever you like
whatever works for your sort situation
and again it's a one-liner and you have
to kind of work out your points and we
had this sort of slightly complicated
design so we did that we were happy to
do that I think we did a mock-up in like
a pen or something to kind of prove the
concept but because we did this shape in
the code we didn't have to go back and
forth of the images constantly it's
quite nice time
and again we were quite happy with this
full back of just the straight lines
it's like edge something that it doesn't
have so that's a quick path on HTML
elements I'm sure you're going to see
more of this later but it gets really
exciting when you stop putting SVG into
the mix with clip path because SPG's
just XML right so you can put text notes
in it you can start doing stuff like
this that's information behind the text
I just think this is very exciting I'd
love to see people are kind of doing
more kind of interesting layouts and
interesting headers an interesting text
with this kind of stuff because it's SVG
as well you could have multiple nodes
inside and you could have you know
multiple kind of window sum to one image
I sort of have this idea that you that
might be quite performant if you have
like a big image with different windows
on it into different areas I'm not
entirely sure if that would work but
sounds like a good idea and let's make a
browser support for tip pal a lot better
this is good um worth noting again this
is for HTML click path on SVG works
pretty much anywhere that SVG is
supported so pretty much everywhere but
again you know looking to your fullbacks
making sure that your progressive
enhancement is you know you've thought
about all the cases so that's it for
practical tips there's a few final
thoughts that I had when I was working
on this stuff and while the team were
working in the home page module things
that I think are just important
takeaways to kind of remember so the
first thing I think is really important
is that all of this stuff not just since
their shapes and clip+ but like anything
that you're using that isn't supported
everywhere like it's not all or nothing
just because some of this stuff is not
supported in every browser doesn't mean
you can't use it it just means that you
can be a bit cleverer about how you
design it and how we build it and
there's a nice tool that can help us do
this so what do you do if you've made a
really nice design but it's a little bit
more complicated than this these are
really simple examples on purpose to
sort of help build up our understanding
triangle since I think circles yeah it
really good but actually you know in my
team in my production website it's gonna
be a little bit more complicated so go
back to the example that I showed you
earlier this is what we wanted to build
and we were quite happy with this fall
back when I showed you this example
before actually I was again simplifying
it there's something wrong with this
picture
very subtly wrong but we were not happy
with this fall back as it stands if you
look at it in the browser only you have
the iframe you can see that it's not
perfectly symmetrical and this is a
problem we weren't actually happy with
this the first time that we did it so we
added some margin so that they do
actually line up great but now we don't
want the margin if the click path is
applied oh I like I'm trying to get
living in confused hmm it's ok we can
get back to this we just reset the
margin inside a feature query so there's
a new thing you might have heard about
it the supports key word we say if click
path is supported then we take away that
margin that we added before when it
isn't supported and again like it's
really simple it's like two lines it
works a lot like the media query syntax
is very similar and I just wanted to
reiterate as well after saying all of
that you don't have to do this if you're
happy with those sort of slightly yeah
I'm symmetrical for back then that's
completely fine if you need to do some
shenanigans and resetting and overriding
and you can just include those in that
supports block and that's fine too
useful that won't be affected
the important thing to remember here is
that yeah and all those other examples
the circle the triangle it was fine we
don't have to do it just defaults back
to a rectangle the supports keyword is
form or when you're in a slightly more
like complicated real-life situation and
you want to finesse the detail you only
have to use supports if an axial
fallback you know something in not happy
with so next up building on that I
suppose
say like this can't be a bold statement
and a bold layout or something like
you're thinking really big or it can
just be a really small enhancement but
the important thing to remember with all
of these things is to remember those
kind of inclusive design patterns so
this is from a real website an example
in the world and one thing I wanted to
highlight here is that all of those sort
of real-world examples that I've seen
have the ragged edge of the text on the
right hand side but not the left and
that's really important in left-to-right
languages reading from ragged edges on
the starting end of the line is really
difficult you're I can't like sort of go
back to the line and find it even more
difficult if you have dyslexia or
anything else though so it makes it
harder if you read but it's it's
difficult for anybody so don't do that
the final thing I wanted to say was this
kind of yeah use it or lose it
I guess this looks a bit dry and it is
with respect for CSS shapes I'm not
really recommending that you like go to
Reno but I think it is kind of important
to keep an eye on stuff like this
it's after all here tonight follow Jemma
Simmons follow Rachel Andrews who's also
writing about CSS grid and other shaped
stuff at the moment full of you other
people who are writing about exciting
stuff because if we don't use it the
browser implement us would just think
that we don't want it and they'll take
it away you know that's actually
happened with CSS shape inside nobody
used it it's slightly more complicated
than they kind of expected it to be it's
gone away until we say that you no
matter we do really want this they do
look to us for feedback and we should
let them know what we want lastly some
other ideas if this has inspired you you
want to find out more about CSS shapes
all right any of these other things
either some other it's sort of
interesting typographical design tweaks
that are coming to the web hopefully
soon I've linked everything up here so
put the slides up later and you can just
click through so that's kind of it
really mainly I just wanted to be to ask
you to be inspired go away make stuff
tell me about how you're getting on
interested in no shapes what you make
and some more people for inspiration
thank you very much